our next guest is the mother of two and
she created a line of masks for the
whole family
and we're so happy that she did and
we're so happy
that she's here from supermodel to
supermom
please welcome karolina korkova
hi hello
how are you drew i'm really good and
i wanted to jump right in by showing you
two pictures of
me i took them this weekend
in honor of you being here and i have to
tell you
i have been wearing this mask non-stop
now
obviously nobody knew masks would be a
thing this year but you and billy blooms
have elevated them to not only a real
fashion accessory but
every time i wear it i feel like i'm
blowing a kiss it's they're just
really incredible quality and they're
optimistic and beautiful
how did this all start well thank you so
much for
saying so many nice things about the
mask uh really when we started with my
friend ashley lemur
back in early april we really wanted to
do something that was giving back and
to our community and to people you know
that were losing
jobs including ashley's um seamstresses
that she's
been working with for uh over 15 years
that you know suddenly
she had to let go and we really being
moms we knew we wanted to create masks
that really were
happy that were um fashionable they were
fun and different
and really make it a little bit more fun
and easier for people to wear them
especially for children you know how do
you tell a three-year-old oh
now suddenly you have to wear these
masks which you know they're not so
comfortable
yes you do get hot underneath them and
so we really worked really hard how can
we make them more comfortable how can we
make them more fun and
so we did embroidery of cats and a dog
which is
our cat kaya and doug bowie and we gave
it also a story to kind of turn this
mask wearing around from being something
that's like
so hard and difficult it's you know what
you are a superhero and even superheroes
don't just wear capes but they wear
masks to protect the people that they
love
around them can i come join your family
because you are an amazing mom and that
is
the type of rhetoric and words words
matter
um they are everything to me and
it is so unique to find
a new language about everything this
year
and how we empower our kids and how we
make them aware
and responsible but keep it not scary
and joyful is one of the most original
unique difficult tight ropes we will
ever walk in our lifetime
and i just have to say that i think what
you are doing
is profoundly important and they're
excellent masks i put them in
the little yellow book this week i am in
love with these and i'm
so grateful for you to do what you are
doing and we here on the show really
celebrate it thank you
carolina for being an amazing woman an
amazing mom and now making a product
that truly works in every single way
thank you thank you and also i forgot to
mention
that from every mask that's purchased
from us
proceeds goes to feeding america and
that really was really important for us
really just
giving back and keeping families safe
and thank you thank you it's been really
incredible journey
and to have something you know during
times where it has been
so you know confusing and you're at home
and especially when
everything started you feel so helpless
you know i'm not a doctor
ashley's not a doctor we felt like we
wanted to do something
and really this project gave us so much
joy and creativity and have
our families and our children being part
of creating these masks for other
children
and you know being our models and test
models and
it's been really incredible and
you know and yes now it's our new
accessory and you know
um it's keeping us safe and keeping it
fun
and beautiful thank you carolina
billyblooms.com
[Music]